ربما لا يوجد كلام يقال في فاجعه يوم امس
لكن لعلنا نذكر نحن ايضا في صباح العربيه
ضحايا الكارثه التي اصابت تركيا وسوريا
فبقوه 7.9 درجات اهتزت الارض تحت ساكنيها
بزلزال كان مركز مدينه غازي عنتاب واصاب
سوريا التي كانت الاكثر تضررا بعد تركيا
ووصلت ارتداداته الى لبنان والعراق ومصر
واليونان وقبرص وارمينيا الزلزال المفجع
خلف الاف الضحايا في تركيا وسوريا فضلا عن
ملايين المشردين الذين دمرت بيوتهم بعد
انهيار مئات المباني بينما يبقى العشرات
حتى الان تحت الانقاض في مشهد مرعب يعيش
سكان جنوب تركيا وشمال ووسط سوريا
والمناطق الساحليه السوريه بعض المراجع
تقول ان هذا الزلزال هو الاكبر في تاريخ
تركيا منذ نحو قرن وهي التي شهدت في
السنوات الاخيره نشاطا زلزاليا ملحوظا كل
حال تفاصيل اوفى مع لميس
منذ القرن الثاني عشر شهدت كل من سوريا
وتركيا ما يزيد عن 20 زلزالا مدمرا تجاوزت
قوتها سبعه درجات على مقياس ريختر وحصدت
الاف الارواح في عام 1509 شاهدت تركيا
زلزالا عرف بالقيامه الصغرى دمر جزءا
كبيرا من اسطنبول ويقال ان تبعاتها استمرت
لاكثر من اربعين يوما وفي عام 1719 ضرب
اسطنبول زلزال مدمر وصلت قوته لمدينه
ازميت ودمر جزءا كبيرا من السوق القديم
للمدينه وكان عام 1999 مرعبا للاتراك حيث
شهدت ولايه مدمرا ادى لقتل 17,000 واصابه
ما يزيد عن 25
وفي سوريا كان زلزال دمشق عام 847 احد
اعنف الزلازل في التاريخ وخلف الاف
الضحايا ووصل تاثيره لانطاكيا والموصل وفي
سنه
2238 شهدت مدينه حلب زلزالا خلف بحسب
الاحصائيات التاريخيه
230 الف قتيل ودمر جزءا كبيرا من المدينه
وشهدت مدينه حماه عام 1257 زلزالا مدمرا
قدر ضحاياه باكثر من عشره الاف وسقطت فيه
عدد من القلاع المبنيه ايهم الحروب
الصليبيه
[موسيقى]
على كل حال لنعرف المزيد من التفاصيل كيف
هو الوضع الان اما في شمال سوريا او حتى
في جنوب تركيا معنا من شمال سوريا من
القامشلي بالتحديد مراسل صباح العربيه
جماعه كاش ومن غرفه التركيه الصحفيه عهد
الصليب اهلا بكم معنا في صباح العربيه وفي
هذه التغطيه الخاصه حول زلزال ليوم امس
عهد معك يعني قبل الساعه من الان تقريبا
ما زالت الهزات الارتداديه تضرب الجنوب
التركي ما حجمها وكيف هو وقعها
نعم صباح
المشاهدين نعم ضربت هزه ارضيه جديده قبل
ساعتين بالضبط من الان في تمام الساعه
السادسه و16 دقيقه مركز ولايه اليمن كانت
يعني درجتها 5.3 على مقياس ريختر يعني شعر
بها جل سكان جنوب التركي وحتى الشمال
السوري والشمال الشرقي السوري حتى
شعر هذه المناطق بهذه الهزه لكنها تعتبر
خفيفه جدا مقارنه بالهزات التي ضربت
المنطقه صباح وظهره الهزتين التي ادت الى
كانت الكبرى في الجنوب التركي والشمال
السوري اذا اردنا الحديث عن يعني ولايه
شارلوفا والجنوب التركي حقيقه الماساه
كبيره جدا اذا تحدثنا عن ولايه جات اورفا
يعني نامت ولايه شارلي اورفا بضحيه بتسجيل
يعني قائمه الضحايا باثنين 60 قتيل ومئات
الجرحى جراء سقوط عدد كبير من الابنيه
منها تتالف من اكثر من عشره طوابق سقطت
على مقربه من نوى استطعنا توثيق هذا الحدث
تحديدا
فيما يتعلق
الجنوبي انا ايضا نرى في المقلب الاخر
وبتحديد في الشمال السوري جماعه عكاش
حقيقه اسئله كثيره في اذهاننا كيف هو
الوضع كيف هو وضع الناس هل ما زالت عمليه
الانقاذ تفضل لك الكلمه صباح الخير نادين
لك ولمشاهدي برنامج صباح العربيه بعد مرور
24 ساعه على بدء هذه الكارثه لا تزال كل
فصول وتجليات الكارثه مستمره في شمال غرب
سوريا وايضا في الساحل والداخل
السوريين نحن نتحدث عن ارتفاع كبير في
اعداد القتلى 1480 قتيل الاف من الاصابات
تدافع على ابواب المشافي الرئيسيه التي
تعمل منذ صباح يوم امس وحتى الان اكثر من
طاقاتها
الاستعاديه الاف من الاسر نامت ليله في
العراق في ظل ظروف البرد القارس وهذا
الشتاء القوي درجات الحراره كانت تحت
الصفر بثلاث درجات نحن يعني امام حاله
وكارثه انسانيه غير مسبوقه وغير معتاده في
تاريخ هذا البلد الذي ارهقته يعني سنوات
طويله من من الحروب
والصراعات تاتي اليوم لتتوج بكارثه طبيعيه
وتشرد
المتشردين اصلا وتنزح وتلجا باللاجين
والنازحين مره اخرى
يعني اوضاع هذا الصباح كان هناك دعوات بان
بدا الناس يعني لا يطالبون فقط بادخال
المساعدات كذا الناس يعني يطلبون فقط
الرحمه
وعهد وجمعه ايضا بين الحطام وبين الركام
مازال الناس يبحثون عن بقعه امل وما زال
العال
قون الضوء لكي يذهبوا الى الخارج من بين
هذا الركاب فهل مازال هناك اشخاص عالقين
عهد ما زالوا تحت الابنيه المهدمه وهل في
عدد تقريبي لعددهم
نعم حقيقه في ولايه شادور يعتبر
ممتاز جدا
حقيقه الاوضاع ماساويه ايه الحشرات
وتطبيق اسماء المفقودين والذين ما زالوا
تحت الانقاظ استطاعت جمع اكثر من 30 اسم
كل اسم هو من يعني يتالف من عائله كامله
ليس فقط شخص واحد قبل قليل توجه احد
الاصدقاء باتجاه ولايه انطاكيا البحث فقط
عن يعني هذه الابنيه ومعرفه ما الذي حصل
كون منطقه انطاكيا الان مقطوعه الاتصالات
عنها بشكل تام من لحظه وقوع الزلزال هناك
من اقاربي حتى الان متواجدين تحت الانقاض
استطاع شخص واحد من العائله الفرار ولكن
بقيه العائله ما تزال حتى هذه اللحظه تحت
الانقاذ في ولايه انطاكيا اخذ ولايه مرعش
التركيه في ولايه اورفا كانت يعني
الاستجابه
الكارثه تعتبر جيده مقارنه مع تلك
الولايات حتى ان يعني القوات الشرطه
والامن التركيه وكذلك الامر الاطفاء
والجهات المسعفه لم تسمح لاحد ان يقت من
المواقع التي يعني دمرت كما لاحظتم يوم
عمل على شاشتكم اثناء تغطيه للحدث لم
يسمحوا لي حتى الاقتراب اكثر من 50 متر
بالقرب من المباني التي سقطت في ولايه
شارلي اورفا لكن الوضع في مرعش الان
الاهالي يطالبون المدنيين بانقاذ الذين ما
زالوهم تحت الانقاض حقيقه لم نستطع تقديم
اي نوع من المساعده لكون الانقاض هي تحتاج
الى معدات كبيره وثقيله من تريكسات او
شابه ذلك
والمدنيين يعني البسطاء لا يملكون هذا
الشيء سوى انهم يسمعون الاصوات تحت
الانقاض حتى هذه اللحظه هناك عائله من
اقاربي في ولايه مرعش وصلت بعض الانباء
بعد انتشار خبر مقتلهم تحت الانقاض في
ولايه مرعش ان هناك اصوات يعني من تحت
الانقاض بان هناك مازال بعضهم احياء على
قيد الحياه حتى عصر امس او ربما وقت
المغرب لكن بعدها اختفت الاصوات بشكل يعني
ولم جمعه يعني الناس يطلبون الرحمه جمعه
اليوم خصوصا في الشمال السوري الذي لم
يهدا طوال عقد من الزمن هل المستشفيات
كفيله مهيئه كافيه لاستقبال هذا العدد من
الجرحى هل حتى الامكانيات اللوجستيه
لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه من الاشخاص
العالقين بين الركام كافيه
يعني نادين القطاع الصحي خلال السنوات
الماضيه كان سيء للغايه بسبب ظروف الحرب
اليوم
من معظم المستشفيات مستشفى عفرين العسكري
مستشفى ادلب المركزي والعيادات المتنقله
اللي قدره بعض المنظمات التامن منها غير
كافي نهائيا لاستيعاب الاعداد المهوله من
المصابين والجرحى يوم امس فقط في مشفى
عفرين شخص فارق الحياه من اصل 103 اشخاص
يعني كان وصلوا الى هذا المشفى يعني
الاطباء اثناء تواصلنا معهم اكدوا بانه تم
ادخال يعني
اربع او خمس اشخاص الى غرف العيناء
المشدده او غرف العمليات وتم اجراء عمليات
جراحيه جماعيه رغم انه هذه العمليات
الجراحيه بتكون عمليات دقيقه وانه اغلب
الناس اللي عم يعانوا من جروح عباره عن
اصابات وقصور الجمجمه او في العظام الجسر
فبالتالي لحتى يقدر يرقدوا اكبر عدد من
الارواح عملوا عمليات جماعيه في مشفى
عفرين العسكري نفس الامر في مشفى ادلب
المركزي يعني الناس في ممرات المعالجتها
في ممرات المشفى وايضا على مداخل المشبع
يعني
بالتاكيد في سياق نشاط الاخبار في العربيه
شكرا جزيلا لكما جمعه عكاش من القامشلي
وايضا من غرفه التركيه عهد الصليب شكرا
لكم